[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va passer toute cette
émission avec l'un des jeunes penseurs
les plus intéressantes notre époque l'un
des plus créatifs il a moins de 40 ans
il est philosophe et sociologue
professeur à l'école nationale
supérieure d'art de paris-cergy bonjour
geoffroy de lagasnerie vous êtes
l'auteur de livres tout à fait originaux
comme l'art de la révolte c'était sur
edouard snowdon julian assange ou
chelsea manning ou bien jugé c'était sur
l'état pénal ou penser dans un monde
mode veille qui expliquait comment ne
pas être complices même involontairement
des systèmes de pouvoir en place
aujourd'hui vous publié chez fayard
sortir de notre impuissance politique
le point de départ est simple la gauche
perd depuis plusieurs décennies la
plupart des combats qu'elle engage il
faut donc qu'elle s'interroge sur sa
façon de lutter qui l'a conduit
systématiquement à la défaite vous
proposer dans ce petit manuel de lutte
de 90 pages de nouvelles stratégies de
nouvelles techniques assez
révolutionnaire quand on va le voir pour
que la gauche sorte enfin de
l'impuissance à laquelle elle semble
être condamnée mais commençons tout de
suite pas l'image que vous avez choisi
pour symboliser ce début de 21e siècle
c'est un portrait de julian assange
pourquoi lui va s'gêner somme c'était
quelqu'un déjà bonjour de la scène c'est
quelqu'un qui occupe une place très
importante dans mon coeur et dans ma
réflexion sur la nouveauté politique au
xxème siècle au 21ème siècle je pense
que wikileaks a été l'une des
organisations les plus puissantes et les
plus déstabilisatrice pour essayer de
réfléchir sur les tasses le droit de
savoir sur la connaissance son espace
public sur le journalisme sur l'anonymat
et puis bien sûr en ce moment il ya son
procès dans lequel il risque d'être
extradé aux états unis d'être peut-être
condamnés à plus de 150 ans de prison ce
qui m'intéresse moi beaucoup avec la
figure de jsm sur la figure de la
dissidence politique aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que traditionnellement dans
l'histoire de la dissidence que ce soit
en afrique du sud avec mandela que ce
soit les dissidents soviétiques
il avait toujours une référence qui
était un peu les pays européens où les
états unis comme lieu d'accueil comme le
modèle dont il pourrait se servir et
invoqué contre les systèmes répressifs
qui les réprimaient et contre lequel il
se battait méprendre quand une figure
comme du n900 on a affaire à des
dissidents des états qui étaient
présentés comme les modèles des anciens
dissidents c'est des états unis
père c'est l'angleterre qui le
persécutent ce sont des juges
indépendants c'est l'état de droit qui
s'applique et qui risque de mettre en
prison soit 50 ans est donc allée d'iéna
scène j'en ai un peu à faire à la
réouverture de l'histoire politique
parce que on est dissidents des
résidents orphelin de tout modèle et de
tout futur des dissidents sans patrie
d'accueil possibles sans modèle
politique plus démocratique qui
pourraient les accueillir
et donc pour moi jen hassan chez
vraiment un peu le l'enjeu le défi qui
se pose à nos systèmes politiques
aujourd'hui c'est de quelle manière est
ce que nous pourrions réinventer les
états la souveraineté le droit de savoir
pourquoi un modèle comme lui puisse
vivre et puissent pleinement exercer sa
profession et non pas être en prison est
menacée de mort voyons maintenant votre
votre nouveau livre sortir de notre
impuissance politique c'est un petit
livre the lady un manuel de lutte il ne
coûte que 5 euros il est édité chez
fayard
le point de départ c'est vous dit que
quand on fait l'expérience de la
politique quand on est un jeune militant
de gauche enfin un militant de gauche
même même moins jeunes ont fait ou font
l'expérience de l'impuissance politique
c'est à dire qu'au fond on n'arrive à
rien toutes les luttes échoue et donc
vous avez écrit ce petit manuel de lutte
pour sortir de cette espèce de spirale
infernale qui dure depuis plusieurs
décennies penser que la gauche un
problème de technique il faut qu'elle
change de tactique
oui moi je pense que ce livre il est né
des luttes il a pour fonction de revenir
au lieu de ce livre il est né du fait
que comme beaucoup de gens si beaucoup
d'engagés ces dix et quinze années dans
les mouvements j'ai fait des
manifestations j'ai fait des occupations
j'ai soutenu des mouvements politiques
de toutes sortes que ce soit sur votre
avec soin sur l'écologie sur la
libération animale sur l'ordre policiers
que soient les gilet jaune et c'est
l'une des choses que je pouvait
constater c'est que ces mouvements même
s'il se déployer depuis une dizaine ou
une quinzaine d'années l'humeur qui
régnait au sein de la jeunesse radicale
ou des militants de longue date c'est le
fait qu'aujourd'hui en gros depuis une
trentaine quarantaine d'années la gauche
échoue dans ces combats la gauche perd
la possibilité de conquérir l'appareil
d'état d'imposer des réformes d'un
progrès d'imposer des ruptures
paradigmatique extrêmement forte par
rapport à la manière dont notre monde
est gouverné que ce soit sur tout un
ensemble de lutins élites économiques et
du carcéral de libération animale et
dites écologiques la domination
masculine le racisme la police etc
c'est un chant de défaite c'est un champ
de ruines et le grand problème moi qui
m'a semblé important de prendre en
compte c'est que malgré le fait que le
sentiment qui caractérise aujourd'hui
les gens qui se définissent comme de
gauche et l'impuissance les sentiments
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est la
tétanie c'est la paralysie
eh bien nous ne remettons pas en cause
de manière d'agir et nous nous
comportons politiquement beaucoup plus
comme des automates comme des stratèges
j'espère que nous fonctionnons toujours
de la même manière
occupation boycott mais métisse etc
on reprend des méthodes de contestation
traditionnel on se définit comme sujet
en lutte par la reprise de ses formes
d'action et jamais on ferait une forme
d'expérience politique c'est-à-dire par
laquelle on prendre une distance par
rapport à notre expérience et par
lesquelles on pourrait se demander
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas lutter
totalement autrement est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas agir totalement autrement
et est ce que la gauche devra pas faire
une forme d'état général de ses
pratiques et de ses luttes pour essayer
de redevenir puissant politiquement moi
j'essaie de bien comprendre les choses
et que vous le dis toujours il faut
croire que quand la gauche perd c'est
que la droite gagne c'est à dire que si
c'est la droite qui gagnent soir que la
droite oscille à des méthodes d'action
la droite aussi elle a des techniques la
droite aussi hélas des méthodes et si
jamais nous perdons ça veut dire que les
méthodes de la droite
les méthodes des forces conservatrices
aux réactionnaires sont plus puissantes
que les méthodes de la gauche donc de
quelle manière est ce que nous pourrions
essayer de réfléchir sur une réinvention
de méthodes puissante aujourd'hui pour
la gauche et qu'est ce que ça voudrait
dire de nos formes de luttes nos formes
de pensée par exemple vous constatez que
presque à chaque fois quand la gauche se
mobilise c'est pour réagir et uniquement
réagir à une décision gouvernementale
patronale c'est toujours être en
position défensive et au fond même quand
elle ne perd pas la gauche comme avec
les retraites par exemple elle ne gagne
pas non plus exactement en fait une des
choses qui m'intéressent beaucoup dans
ce livre c'est d'essayer de penser de
quelle manière est ce qu'il ya une
logique perverse qui s'est mise en place
dans la gauche aujourd'hui qui est que
précisément c'est quand elle agit et
crottes quand elle croit qu'elle agit
bien à quel âge est une façon puissante
que en fait elle est en train de
s'autodétruire d'excès pas tellement
qu'elle n'agit pas qu'ils aient fait
qu'elle perce est précisément parce
qu'elle
les précédents parce qu'elle se croit
efficace que dans ces moments là elle
est prise dans une logique perverse de
la perte est de la défaite est l'une des
choses qui manifestent en fait cette
auto mutilation de la gauche c'est le
fait que à mon avis depuis les années 80
on a connu une forme d' inversion de la
temporalité politique on peut dire que
36 47 68 ont été les grands mouvements
où la gauche était conquérante où la
gauche de demander et voulait imposer
aux gouvernants des choses c'était des
grèves pour plus de congés payés pour
plus de salaire pour des
nationalisations me contre les pour son
indemnisation des droits du travail à la
fin des années du 10ème siècle et c'est
adopter pour des conquêtes pense
mobilisés alors depuis les années 80 les
grands mouvements sociaux qu'ont les
rentes est contre le cpe contre la loi
travail contre la réforme des retraites
contre le plan juppé
c'est sur des mouvements contre c'est à
dire que ce sont des mouvements qui
réagissent à la réaction qui réagissent
à ce que fait l'état et le grand
problème de c'est un mouvement qui se
définit de façon réactive c'est que même
quand on gagne quand on dit qu'on a
gagné par exemple au moment du contrat
première embauche en 2005 qui reste un
moment très important à dans
l'imaginaire de la ville de gauche ont
dit cette dernière lutte qu'on a gagné
en fait on n'a pas gagné on n'a pas
perdu c'est à dire qu'en fait on a
seulement réussi à faire qu'un projet
conservateur ne passe pas mais en fait
on a conservé l'ordre existant et on n'a
rien changé on n'a rien imposer et ça
c'est très très important parce que
dépense définit comme réagissant aux
forces de la réaction
ce qu'on appelle gagner c'est conserver
le présent et donc à une opération
perverse qui se met en place qui
consiste à devoir présenter le présent
quand quelque chose de valoriser comme
quelque chose qu'on veut conserver comme
quelque chose qu'on aime on est content
de le garder et deux compères même si on
gagne puisqu'on a ratifié l'ordre qu'on
critique et auparavant on la premiére
vue sur la question de la réforme des
retraites avec macron l'a récemment qui
m'a beaucoup frappé caen mâcon produit
une réforme de la retraite à points en
disant on va sortir du système par
répartition
tout d'un coup on a vu l'ensemble des
intellectuels les syndicalistes aller
sur les plateaux télé d'hier c'est le
meilleur système au monde le sait le
système le plus protecteur cesser le
plus généreux c'est le système qui
protège le mieux la question des les
femmes des carrières hachées etc etc et
donc tout d'un coup on s'est mis à
valoriser un système que l'on critiqué
auparavant sur les inégalités sont des
petites retraites sur la question des
retraites de misère et ses rites et de
rapports au travail les chômeurs et tout
est donc paradoxalement la lutte par
exemple contre la retraite à points
elle a construit ce tte a présenté comme
positif quelque chose que nous
critiquons auparavant et donc nous avons
perdu de terrain et donc ma théorie à
moi c'est que dès qu'on réagit au
pouvoir on perd même si on gagne
pères parce que on est amené à définir
comme positif l'ordre qu'on critique
auparavant et donc une gauche ne peut
être puissante que si elle est proactive
et jamais scellé réactive et de la même
manière par la gauche passe pour
réactionnaire au fond elle préférait
avant le monde d'avant et sans arrêt
décrit comme meilleur que celui
d'aujourd'hui
donc on a l'impression que la gauche
c'est le passé et les et les réformes
quelle qu'elle soit de droite du centre
celle à venir au fond oui parce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est quand même assez
faux c'est une forme de tonalité
passéiste dans la gauche
un ton pastelliste qui s'est installé
depuis une vingtaine d'années c'est à
dire et moi je parle d'un livre delà du
triomphe de la pensée des c'est à dire
qu'on analyse tous les systèmes de
pouvoir et toutes les offensives
les forces réactionnaires commune
quelque chose qui le défait quelque
chose ça démantèle ça des structures ce
après qu'harry sacré de l'exception et
c'est la gangrène a été l'un des grands
penseurs de cette force là mais dès que
vous analysez le présent où le futur
vous lit par les forces conservatrices
comme dit que le fait de défaire quelque
chose en fait paradoxalement vous mettez
en position de valoriser l'ordre passé
et de le présenter comme étant plus
protecteur plus généreux plus
rationnelle que l'avant et donc vous
faites régner dans la gauche une pensée
passéiste le néolibéralisme est l'un des
mots comme moi j'essaie de critiquer
dans livres on y reviendra mais le mot
néolibéralisme le concept au
néolibéralisme jouent un rôle très très
nocif dans la gauche
et ce qui est toujours analysé comme une
force destructrice du commun du
politique de l'amour de l'intimité je
sais pas quoi n'importe quoi et donc
paradoxalement on va présenter comme ce
que le néolibéralisme des faits comme
positif pour critiquer néolibéralisme et
donc on en vient à valoriser la famille
l'autre prises le travail et les cadres
collectifs ont critiqué auparavant pour
commettre des sources de pouvoir et donc
effectivement et ce n'est a régné dans
la gauche une forme d'humeur passéiste
une humeur une conservatrice même en un
sens parce que la gauche n'arrive pas au
ne tient pas une capacité à produire des
systèmes autonomes des analyses et des
forces politiques progressistes entente
n 2 de même quand on est un militant de
gauche on va et qu'on proteste
on va toujours s'adresser aux patrons au
gouvernement au fond à ce qu'on ne
changera jamais dit d'où on se trompe de
cible c'est pas à eux que la gauche
devrait parler
alors voilà la grande question après
c'est une fois qu'on a compris qu'on
perd des repères des toutes les luttes
alors après on pourra s'interroger sur
les formes rituel une équation j'essaie
de poser dans l'iss et de quelle manière
est ce que nos tactiques sont vouées à
l'échec que par essence et de quelle
manière ce que nous voulions re définir
de manière de nous définir comme de
gauche stratégie de visibilité de
rapports à l'espace public de la prise
de parole est l'une des choses qui moi
me frappe par exemple c'est
qu'effectivement lorsque nous nous
mobilisons lorsque nous voulons
intervenir
nous allons très souvent nous adresser
aux domine nous allons nous adresser à
ceux qui ont du pouvoir sur nous alors a
par exemple des pétitions auris de
l'intérieur sur la question des
pratiques policières une âme un peu au
ministre des affaires étrangères ou
président de la république au ministre
du travail sur les accidents du travail
etc et donc nous faisons c'est une forme
de forme d' adresse dans lequel se
mobiliser à gauche ce serait s'adresser
aux dominants et ce serait essayer de
les convaincre et envoie sur les
plateaux télé parfois ou même dans les
essais en disant qu'ils vont dire j'ai
fait un lit pour montrer l'art et les
accidents du travail pour montrer
l'arrêté de la police à castanet dans la
kasma macro et c'est comme s'il l'ignoré
comme s'il savait pas précisément ce qui
se passe tous ses étés complètement
ignorant la réalité
moi j'ai une théorie c'est que les
dominants savent très bien la réalité
peut-être menthe dessus mais la
connaissent et là veulent en vérité au
veulent la conserver ou veulent la grave
et est donc en quelque sorte la question
que je pose c'est est-ce que c'est très
intéressant de s'adresser aux démunis ou
est-ce que c'est du temps perdu puisque
ce sont des gens qui veulent la réalité
est qu'on ne changera jamais est un
allié à un très intéressant procureur
noir américain paul butler qu'avec un
livre c'est l'étouffement sur la
question du système carcéral américain
et qui parle la question de la sueur
incarcération massive des noirs aux
états unis qui est un phénomène
absolument majeur et incontesté et qui
dit qu'il ya un biais dans les milieux
militants sur ces questions anticarcéral
de racisme institutionnel aux états unis
en disant qu'en fait toujours comme s'il
ne savait pas qu'il y avait des meurtres
policiers que les blancs ne savais pas
qu'il y avait une incarcération de la
civ et donc on va faire des
documentaires pour le montrer pour leur
enseigner pour le comté et les dix messi
non seulement il le savait mais c'est ce
qu'ils voulaient parce qu'ils en tirent
des profits en termes de moins de
concurrence au marché du travail en
interne le suprématisme blanc en terme
de racisme tout simplement
et donc est ce que c'est très
intéressant d'essayer de les convaincre
de quelque chose qu'ils savent déjà et
donc est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
construire à gauche du circuit autonome
qui s'adresserait non pas en fait
aux dominants aux gens qui occupent les
positions installé qu'on ne changera
jamais mais aux jeunes c'est à dire à
ceux qui sont susceptibles dans dix ans
dans 20 ans dans trente ans de prendre
leur place et de transformer les
politiques il ya un rapport à mon avis
entre la politique et la démographie le
site thomascook est un historien des
sciences et qui raconte que quand aux
vrais cher sur une révolution
scientifique dans un champ où il ya des
paradigmes incompatibles en vérité le
paradigme qui gagnent c'est par l'imoca
les jeunes avec lui s'évadant la
discussion que ça se règle ça serait de
la démographie c'est à dire que si
jamais vous avez les jeunes avec vous et
20 20 ans après les plus âgés qui
adhèrent au paradigme anciens partent à
la retraite les jeunes arrivent avec un
nouveau paradigme et danser ce paradigme
qui s'impose est donc en fait il voulait
gagner une révolution scientifique vous
devez conquérir les jeunes les positions
de pouvoir qui paraît d'influencer les
jeunes d'où le rôle de l'université
moi je dis un peu pareil dit qu'on fait
de la politique il faut la comprendre
comme du temps alors c'est difficile
parce qu'il ya des urgences de pratique
mais en fait si nous voulons être
puissant il faut essayer de s'affranchir
d'une forme de 2,2 de prison de
l'urgence qui nous conduit à la voir des
stratégies inefficaces en nous adressant
aux dominants pour que de nous adresser
aux jeunes d'avoir des stratégies de
long terme pour changer les structures
mentales
les jeunes et qui a un prêtre pourront
implémenter des politiques qui vont dans
un sens le plus progressiste au fond est
ce que vous dites est encore plus
révolutionnaire vous dites il vaudrait
mieux organiser des manifestations
devant les lycées que devant un
ministère et il vaudrait mieux donner
des conférences à l'université que se
faire inviter sur bfm ou sur lci
parce qu'en fait sur bfm et chef si on
est regardé par des gens de plus de 65
ans au fond
en gros ma théorie c'est ça c'est qu'on
a une un billet c'est ça qui est
vraiment fou c'est qu'on a un biais de
confondre les endroits importants et un
endroit non important et on est
prisonnier d'une forme de manière dont
le pouvoir nous oriente vers des lieux
qui en fait nous
des possède une capacité de l'action
dans le mauvais bout nous font croire
qu'on est en train d'agir et c'est ça la
logique perverse que j'essaie d'analyser
dans mon livre c'est mais d'autres
d'auto mystification c'est à dire c'est
plaisant quand nous croyons agir que
nous sommes en train de perdre
et effectivement quand on réfléchit en
termes de stratégie politique efficace
qu'est ce que c'est le plus efficace est
ce que ça valait de vent de l'histoire
de l'intérieur dire à un ministre qui
lie à des pratiques policières
inacceptable dans les commissariats dans
les quartiers populaires ce qu'il sait
ce que tout le monde sait et qu'on ne
changera pas est ce qu'il le veut et qui
est il le sait déjà qu'il devait changer
leurs effets ou est-ce qu'au contraire
c'est d'essayer d'aller convaincre ceux
qui sont susceptibles de le remplacer et
donc est ce qui n'est pas beaucoup plus
par exemple important d'aller faire une
tournée des lycées que d'aller à la
matinale de france inter où dès lundi
dans le média faire un entretien ou en
fait on se fait plaisir ou en fait on a
une visibilité forte mais est ce que
cette visibilité là elle pas une manière
pour le pouvoir en fait de dire oui oui
c'est bien fait bien dit-on propos ça a
marché mais en fait nous a vraiment
coupé des lieux effectifs de la
transformation sociale et donc j'essaie
de transformer un peu dans mon livre les
lieux où ça compte ou c'est important de
faire des choses est ce qu'il vaut
beaucoup mieux aller parler à quinze
lycéens aller à parler à quinze
collégiens ou à l'épargné dans une
chaîne où on ait eu que par des
individus qui sont prédisposés à ne pas
changer vous prédispose et ne plus
pouvoir change le la politique c'est du
temps et c'est quelque chose de très
compliqué à comprendre
ou plutôt à accepter parce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut accepter une
inefficacité présente pour une
efficacité dans vingt ans et il faut
savoir renoncer au mythe de
l'immédiateté quand on est à gauche
je pense par exemple que l'on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est gouverné par des
gens qui ont des cerveaux qui ont été
formés dans les écoles de pouvoir dans
les écoles de commerce ou dans les
instituts d'études publiques politiques
pardon dans les années 80 dans les
années 90
et on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui en fait
on vit dans les années 80 ont vite dans
les années 90 en vie avec des gens qui
ont incorporé les logiciels des
perceptions des catégories de penser
qu'ils ont appris ce que vous avez vingt
ou trente ans dans les partis politiques
ou dans les écoles
lorsqu'il était jeune mais la
conséquence de ça c'est à dire que nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans 20 ans en vérité
nous vivons aujourd'hui dans trente ans
nous vivrons en 2000
en 2050 c'est à dire que ce sont des
individus qui ont été formés dans les
structures mentales ont été formés
aujourd'hui qui gouverneront dans 20 ans
et c'est à ce moment là on peut essayer
d'agir dans le futur en agissant
aujourd'hui sûr on pourrait dire la même
chose que mitterrand arrive au pouvoir
en 81 parce qu'il ya eu mais 68 13 ans
avant exactement je pense que c'est un
coeur le temps d'incubation pas d'une
cumulativité ouais c'est en accusation
c'est le temps où la gauche avait un
programme à mon avis assez fort on
pourra peut-être y revenir mais
effectivement je pense que l'élection de
mitterrand est un très bon exemple du
temps politique et du temps que met une
transformation des structures mentales
notamment chez les plus jeunes pour
pouvoir produire des effets dix quinze
ans après mais en même temps on veut
changer les choses à court terme vous ce
que vous proposez c'est long terme parce
que le court je ne sais pas si c'est une
opposition
en fait c'est pas une pause ce n'est pas
l'oppression pertinence et queue leu leu
le grand problème c'est que l'on ait
affaire d urgence on affaire déjà en
prison on a affaire à des migrants qui
meurt on a affaire à des gens qui ont
faim comme les gilet jaune à le faire à
des femmes battues de qu'on a affaire à
des urgences et c'est évidemment
extrêmement compliqué de dû rejoindre
non mais attendez c'est dans vingt ans
que ça changera il faut bien gérer les
problèmes immédiatement après la
question que moi je bossais que deux
fait cette réponse là en terme a- à
l'urgence on peut pas se fonder sur
votre stratégie
moi je réponds que si c'était vrai que
vous aviez raison qu'on aurait changé
les choses en ça ne change pas pour ça
change très peu voir ce que ça s'aggrave
en vérité et donc à une certaine manière
de croire à la nécessité du court terme
qui en fait nous fait perdre à court
terme et à long terme alors que
peut-être mais stratégie beaucoup plus
raisonnables rationnelle stratégique de
la gauche pourrait elle enfin produire
des effets réels dans un certain nombre
de gens alors là où vous êtes se livrer
et et sortir de notre impuissance
politique est assez révolutionnaire
encore une fois puisqu'il demande à la
gauche de changer de tactique au riad et
tactique qui sont profondément ancrées
et dans l'histoire et dans la mythologie
de la gauche par exemple la grève
vous dites la grève ça fonctionne point
ça fonctionne plus il faut commencer à
réfléchir autrement
en tout cas ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il
faut des fétichisé les images de la
gauche il faut pas penser qu'il ya des
méthodes d'action qui sont données qui
sont évidentes et qu'il faut forcément
considérée comme étant nécessaire
lorsqu'on est en lutte devoir faire
grève manifesté aucune raison que des
formes historiques constituer un certain
moment du temps et aucune raison de les
fétichisé comme étant les sens de la
lutte aux laissant aux méthodes de lutte
et qu'on pourrait pas agir autrement ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
je m'appuie beaucoup au début du livre
sur un philosophe allemand qui s'appelle
gunther enders
et qui dit quelque chose de très très
beaux en fait sur les formes rituel de
la politique un seul il s'appelle la
violence horrible nous y réfléchissons
la nécessité du recours à la violence
milito d'accord d'accord d'ailleurs et
il dit günther anders en fait une chose
qui est très très étrange dans les
méthodes de lutte de la gauche c'est que
il ya deux formes qui sont sans cesse
reprise soit ce sont des formes auto
sacrificielle c'est à dire on se fait du
mal à soi même et encore qu'on va faire
peur aux dominos ans intimidant soi même
ça c'est l'exemple de la grève de la
faim dont il dit que c'est l'exemple
plus paradigmatique et puis la grève
étant l'exemple le plus courant survie
de cette logique auto sacrificielle du
sujet politique qui croit qu'il agit
quand il se blesse lui même et pas celui
qu'il blesse et puis il dit sinon c'est
des happenings spears a fait céder
espèce de mise en scène de soi comme
sujet qui lutte mais sur le mode du
comme sion fait comme si on agissait en
fait comme si on a fait quelque chose
c'est la manifestation on va sortir les
guitares on va chanter on va faire des
sales fille pour mettre sur instagram on
dit c'était une très belle manif et
rentre chez soi puis voilà on n'a rien
fait du tout est donc en fait l'idée que
la gauche allait prisonniers aux
logiques de l'auto sacrifices aux
logiques du spectacle et que selon lui
ça ne peut pas être efficace
politiquement parce que ce qui est
efficace politiquement c'est de menacer
ce qui nous menace tous ses biens
placé c'est à dire de trouver des modes
d'action beaucoup plus puissant en
vérité et ce avec la grève moi je fais
tes fils part il ya des grèves à
l'échelle locale qui ont marché les
femmes de ménage dans des hôtels pour
les tickets restaurant on peut être
entravé sa pour les réguler récession
sans papiers il ya quelques
manifestations à l'échelle locale qui
peut fonctionner sous la forme de la
grève mais la pose du national la grève
aujourd'hui elle est vouée à l'échec car
je pense que le le l'exemple du
mouvement sur les retraites pour moi a
été un mouvement 4 enfin
caractéristiques de ça il faut quand
même rappeler qu'à paris a pas une mais
trop peu en trois sets on a jamais vu on
a toujours pensé que temps d'arrêter le
métro tous les gouvernements c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est un truc que tout le
monde a pensé moi le premier et je me
suis dit c'est en train de faire ça
c'est magique il ya une métro à paris je
passe vous venez à noël dernier avait
pas de métro à paris et toutes les
lignes étaient fermés pour y avait deux
lignes ouvert ne sais pas et ça n'a rien
changé du tout le gouvernement n'a rien
dit il a comme destituer la grève de son
pouvoir d'action et donc la question que
je me pose est ce avec tout l'argent
coûte une grève avec tous que sa demande
comme logistique aux mobilisations
d'énergie est ce qu'on aurait pu faire
des modes d'action beaucoup plus
efficace beaucoup plus ciblées beaucoup
plus stratégique beaucoup plus réfléchi
plutôt que de reprendre une forme
d'action rituel qui ne prenaient pas et
qui ne marchait pas bien un arbitraire
de la politique parfois ça prend parfois
ça prend c'est comme ça c'est très
important
il ya des mouvements y prenne il y a une
ampleur le gouvernement cède etc et
parfois ça prend pas et quand ça prend
pas il faut savoir y renoncer pour
trouver d'autres formes nature beaucoup
plus à mon avis est ciblée et efficace
stratégique et de fait je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que la grève
n'est plus une forme d'action efficace
politiquement et danser ce qui pourrait
les remplacer ses formes d'actions
ciblées vous citer le cas des black
panthers qui est agissait concrètement
se substituant au pouvoir en place c'est
à dire alors on se souvient des black
panthers donne en organisant des petits
déjeuners pour les enfants mais aussi
des black panthers qui au départ est à
partie d'autodéfense patrouillons dans
la ville et vérifiant que les policiers
ne
ne sont pas en train de de céder à la
violence et étant capable de se mettre
entre les policiers violents et leurs
victimes
absolument une fois qu'on a dit qu' il
faut reprendre l'initiative du temps
politique et qu'il faut cesser de réagir
à l'état mais qu'il faut essayer de
produire le temps politique et produire
des actions qui mettent était sur la
défensive nos pas nous qui nous
défendons l'état mais nous qui mettons
l'état sur la défensive il faut
réfléchir à des modèles action proactive
qui font le temps politique et les modes
d'action pas des modes d'expression dans
le livre est construit autour d'une
opposition entre les modes d'action les
modes d'expression et les modes défensif
et les mode proactif et je pense que le
modèle qui devrait être le modèle de la
gauche en vérité c'est l'action directe
c'est-à-dire qui est par définition une
action que vous produisez votre propre
légalité vous succéder au gouvernement
quelle que soit entre produisez votre
propre loi et d'autre part vous forcer
les tailles sur la défensive parce que
c'est vous qui agissez qui produisait la
légalité que vous voulez voir venir pour
moi l'un des exemples majeur de ça ces
derniers temps ça a été la lutte sur la
question migratoire avec c'est vrai
qu'air vous avec paula raquette en
italie par exemple qui honore les gens
qui vont affréter des bateaux pour aller
chercher des migrants qui se noyait
sinon dans la méditerranée quand vous
faites ça en fait vous substituer à
l'état brut est à moi j'avais une
légalité ou ses gens son secours où ces
gens sont accueillis ou ces gens sont en
effet le médecin est en fait c'est à
l'état de réagir à l'autre action vous
avez produit votre cahier de notes
l'égalité vous êtes produit votre
temporalité vous êtes produit ce que
vous voulez voir advenir dans le monde
est en quelque sorte vous efforcez
l'état et serait défensive et ce qu'on a
au obtenu est ce qu'on a observé c'est
que ces actions elles ont produit des
régressions de l'état soeur kate a été
objet de régresser par exemple sur
cédric héros c'était à mon avis assez
peu commenté c'est qu'en se battant sur
la question du principe de fraternité
sur la droit de d'agir pour emmener les
migrants
chez un médecin et puis au genou et c
est bien il était jusqu'au conseil
constitutionnel et il a fait
constitutionnaliser le principe de
fraternité fait casser la loi sur le
délit de solidarité et constitue une
alizé la fraternité franchement vous
ouvrez un champ de l'innovation
juridique extrêmement puissante refaite
pourra lire sur l'état et donc pas où la
raquette par exemple en italie en ayant
débarqué des bateaux contre la décision
de salvini
aujourd'hui c'est sa ligne que ni en
examen pour mauvais traitements en
italie et c'est elle qui est considéré
par les russes comme bien agi et le cas
d'urgence et les droits de l'année il ya
le cas de 269 libération animale que
vous souhaitez que vous citez également
qu'ils libèrent des animaux animal pour
moi c'est l'un des groupes les plus
puissants de la politique l'un des
groupes les plus beaux d'une association
de libération animale qui pratiquent
l'action directe c'est-à-dire qui rompt
avec des associations qui se contente de
faire des vidéos d'abattoirs de mauvais
traitement des animaux et qui vont en
fait seulement comme conséquence
d'envoyer quelques ouvriers en prison de
temps en temps
l'idée de 230 libération animale c'est
qu' il faut faire plus que ça il faut
aller libérer les animaux des abattoirs
donc ils organisent des actions directes
dans les caniveaux bloquer des chaînes
d'exécution ou rentrer dans les
abattoirs et libérer un certain nombre
d'animaux et ensuite les faire vivre
dans un certain nombre de sanctuaires et
ensuite mené une guérilla juridique sur
la nécessité sur le droit de protéger
des individus de la mise à mort avec
leur avocat qui va remonter jusqu'à la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
notamment est donc là on a affaire à une
forme de reprise de l'initiative là
encore du temps politique est ce qu'on
peut constater par exemple c'est que
jamais ils ne sont condamnés à rendre
les animaux aux abattoirs ils ont tous
envolés en fait et de ce point de vue là
on boxe et des individus qui sont sauvés
que les tailles sont sur la défensive
cède un peu de terrain et donc de ce
point de vue là moi je crois
effectivement là l'action directe est
souvent un peu vu comme trop radicale au
tout le fait de groupes minoritaires ou
de l'excès etc ou de groupes violents
etc
moi je crois qu'on peut faire ça devrait
être la forme de référence de la gauche
aujourd'hui comme la grève l'été au 19e
siècle pour moi c'est la forme d'action
la plus puissante la plus innovante et
la plus stratégiquement intelligente et
il faudrait penser l'action directe
comme étant la forme de référence des
milieux radicaux et non pas comme une
forme un peu excentrique alors l'action
directe encore une fois en tant que
bannière de se substituer au pouvoir l
état et par action directe le groupe
terroriste qu'on a connu parce que la
violence en revanche on va en parler
juste après une pause
vous là aussi il ya un vrai problème
mais on fait d'abord une pause on
retrouve geoffroy de lagasnerie juste
après
[Musique]
on revient avec geoffroy de lagasnerie
qui publie sortir de notre impuissance
politique aux éditions fayard c'est un
manuel de lutte mais révolutionnaire au
sens où ils oublient toutes les vieilles
tactiques de la gauche qui ne marchent
plus qui créent de l'impuissance
politique et il tente d'en inventer de
nouvelles qui pourraient leur être
substituée vous parliez d'action directe
pour vous l'action c'est le droit c'est
de l'action
vous le disiez d'ailleurs un vous disais
quand on parvient devant le conseil
constitutionnel a institutionnalisé le
devoir de fraternité le droit et le
devoir de fraternité on est tous changé
vous allez plus loin vous dites au fond
aujourd'hui si on veut changer les
choses il faut être juge si on est de
gauche
il faut une juge il faudra il faut
devenir magistrat plutôt quatre avocats
généralement les gens de gauche préfère
être avocat venons soyez magistrat là
vous changerait les choses donc on peut
changer les choses de l'intérieur mais a
tant qu'à faire oui autant devenir juste
que devenir avocat après tout beaucoup
de gens qui sont aux études de droit par
exemple ce qui se pense très à gauche
anti carcéral enterré pressions vont
vouloir devenir avocat et moi j'avais
parlé de ça dans un colloque d'avocats
et j'avais dit mais peut-être qu'en fait
c'est beaucoup plus intelligente et
beaucoup plus stratégiquement puissant
de devenir juge devenir procureur de
devenir au conseil constitutionnel est
ce qu'il vaut mieux comme anarchiste
occupe une zad éternellement ou est ce
qu'il vaut mieux au conseil
constitutionnel est ce qu'on pourrait
pas imaginer des les révolutions
beaucoup plus puissante de ce point de
vue là et je pense que les choses qu'on
oublie beaucoup à gauche alors pas
tellement aux états unis ou en
angleterre où il ya des traditions
d'activisme juridique mais en france
c'est comment le droit peut être un
terrain de transformation sociale et
politique extrêmement puissant
extrêmement important il faut comprendre
que par exemple aux états unis les
quelques unes des plus grandes conquêtes
notamment l'avortement le mariage gay et
lesbien l'abolition de la ségrégation
sans passer par le conseil
la cour suprême n'est pas par des
élections et pas par des parlements et
donc c'est l'activisme juridique en
vérité eu des plaintes contre l'état qui
ont permis de renverser des décisions
autoritaires de l'état est de protéger
la liberté des individus beaucoup
beaucoup de conquêtes aux états unis par
exemple sur la question de la protection
contre la violence policière et des
interrogatoires le droit d'avoir un
avocat sans passer par des juges qui lui
ont imposé sa à l'ensemble de la
population et qui s'est pas du tout
passé par des majorités et donc moi je
pense qu'effectivement le droit et doit
être conçue comme un instrument
extrêmement malléable avec le droit vous
pouvez
bien condamne les gens très très
fortement ou peut être est bien libérer
des gens trouver des excuses autres des
circonstances atténuantes faire de la
prescription et c'est le droit est un
instrument d'imagination à ce moment de
rationalisation extrêmement fort
extrêmement puissant et je pense
qu'effectivement nous devrions essayer
au maximum de relayer l'action directe
dans le cadre aussi d'une guérilla
juridique est de concevoir l'action
juridique comme étant l'une des formes
essentielles de l'action politique on le
voit par exemple sur la question
écologistes on sait qu'il ya des
plaintes qui sont portées par des jeunes
contre l'état pour ne pas avoir protégé
leur santé moi je pense que porter
plainte contre eux et à démultiplier les
guérilla juridique aller dans les
instances supérieures le conseil le
corps prennent des droits de l'homme etc
etc
le cd forme d'action extrêmement
puissante est beaucoup plus puissante
peut-être que les formes d'action rituel
de la gauche qu ils venaient sentiment
d'agir mais qui en fait nous dépossède
de du contact avec un endroit concret de
la transformation politique alors c'est
d'autant plus intéressant comme
proposition que jusqu'à présent une des
grandes mythologies de la gauche ça
consistait à démissionner en général si
on est de gauche et qu'on est juge on
démissionne
si on est si on est de gauche et qu'on
est policier on démissionne vous vous
dites non faut pas déficit non seulement
faux pas démissionné mais faut y entrer
il faut y entrer il faut affirmer sa
présence et sa présence aux gones de
tactiques d'infiltration politique il ya
un concept que je reprends de la théorie
de la communication dans mon livre
s'appelle la spirale du silence qu'une
théorie vraiment très très véridique
dans les institutions
vous avez une tendance à la disparition
des opinions perçu au considéré comme
minoritaires par le fait que les
individus ont tendance à croire qu'une
opinion est majoritaire
même si elle n'est pas d'ailleurs et
quand les individus vont penser que le
consensus par exemple les conservateurs
tous les gens qui sont un peu de gauche
un peu progressif de peur d'être
sanctionnés de peur de perdre leur
travail de peur d'être mal vus vont se
taire et c'est comme tous les gens qui
ont la même opinion vont penser pareil
tout le monde master et c'est ce qu'on
appelle la spirale du silence qui fait
que deux fait publiquement il apparaît
que c'est les opinions conservatrices
apparaissent comme étant puissante et
donc tout le monde et confirmés dans le
fait qu'il aux minoritaires et tout le
monde se tait mais ça peut très bien
être la conséquence du fait que
l'opinion conservatrice n'est pas du
tout majoritaire mais ça manque à les
imaginer comme étant majoritaire et moi
j'ai beaucoup observé par exemple dans
l'université où j'avais passé une partie
de ma carrière à quel point il ya une
croyance et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très important sur la défaite de la
gauche que les conservateurs sont
dominants qu'il ya des censures qu'il ya
dès qu'il ya des résistances et donc
c'est au nom de résistance invoqué dans
le futur qu'on opère les sens sur prêts
on est en tu pourras jamais faire ça ou
c'est impossible je vais me faire mal
voir alors remettre si vous voulez
imposer ça se passe très bien
et en fait vous rencontrez pas du tout
la censure qui était invoquée est que
très souvent les les comportements sont
son sont plaquées sur des
représentations de ce qu'il faudrait
faire qui n'a rien à voir avec ce qui
laisserait possible de faire et je pense
que l'institution de la justice par
exemple dans l'université
peut-être dans la police dans les
affaires étrangères dans l'économie il
ya beaucoup cette tendance aujourd'hui à
se sentir faible a pas osé s'exprimer
quand on est de gauche quand on est
radicale à à penser qu'on va être
sanctionné et alors que peut-être que
s'il y avait une prise de parole une
affirmation beaucoup plus puissantes de
la présence d'individus progressiste et
vivent dans ces institutions dans la
spirale du silence marchera dans l'autre
sens et on pourrait faire un
fonctionnement opérer un fonctionnement
révolutionnaire aux transformateurs de
cette institution
lorsqu'il fait partie de la panoplie du
militant de la gauche radicale et cela
depuis au mois le 19e siècle c'est la
violence la violence ça me semble être
un passage obligé
à un moment il faut brûler des voitures
il faut casser des vitrines
il faut aller à l'affrontement avec la
police c'est très important
vous dites ça ne sert à rien et en plus
c'est contre-productif alors sur la
violence déjà jean j'y consacre quelques
pages mais pas énormément parce que je
pense que c'est un sujet qu'il est trop
obsédant en vérité de la fin toute
réflexion sur l'action politique
devienne réflexion sur la violence sur
la police est ce qu'il faut casser ce
qu'il faut brûler et moi je pense que
c'est un sujet important c'est notre mai
qui doit pas être le centre de nos
préoccupations voilà il faut pas être
absorbé par une pétition isation comme
ça de la violence et j'essaie de
réfléchir un peu à ça purement
stratégiquement et politiquement que moi
je ne défileront pas une position non
violente on ne croit pas la non violence
dans un monde où il ya de l'appareil
coercitif l'appareil d'état où il ya des
antagonismes à lorient ça n'existe pas
quand vous dites que vous êtes non
violent en fait ce que vous dites c'est
que vous acceptez de laisser le monopole
de la violence à l'état c'est à dire que
les gens qui disent qu'ils sont non
violents mais qui occupent des
supermarchés ou qui font des sit in dans
la rue à la fin ils acceptent que c'est
la prise qui va prendre leur corps qui
va les sortir qu'avec les mettre en
garde à vue qui va peut-être les
sanctionner et donc en fait ils ne sont
pas non violent mais ils se soumettent à
la violence d'état et les acceptent de
considérer qu'il est légitime que la
violence d'état s'applique à eux donc
ils ne sont pas d'un point de vue
holistique non violent mais ils sont en
fait soumis à la violence d'état donc à
lorient ça n'existe pas
la question c'est est-ce que c'est nous
qui pratiquons
violence ou est-ce que c'est l'état qui
est là qui la pratiquent ou les
gouvernants en tout cas qui la
pratiquent l'autre candidat moi j'ai pas
de problème éthique avec la la
production des actions violentes de
confrontation avec les objets du monde
social doit avec la police je pense
qu'on peut tout à fait le comprendre
certaines situations d'étouffement que
sur le moment soit pris comme ça griser
par une forme de nécessité de laisser
exploser une forme de colère et
d'hostilité vois pas ce qu'il y'a
incarne un blocage de votre action ça
pour moi j'ai défendu beaucoup beaucoup
de militants qui avaient été incarcérés
pour des actions de cette nature mais en
même temps je constate et je réfléchis
sur le fait que le rapport de forces est
un désavantage dans le monde social
c'est à dire que deux fêtes lorsque vous
agissez de manière violente
forcément vous suscité la réaction de
l'appareil répressif d'état et des
gouvernements qui ont dans leur pouvoir
de force quand même énorme qui s'appelle
la police et la prison eu la justice et
qui vont vous incarcérées qui veut nous
faire disparaître en fait publiquement
part la prison ou par des amendes ou par
les sursis ou par des contrôles
judiciaires et c est en fait vous allez
vous auto sacrifier vous hâtez vous
allez vous éliminez de l'espace de la
lutte et quand vous avez cru vous avez
agi en fait ce que vous avez fait c'est
que vous êtes auto détruit comme sujet
politique et vous avez juste fait une
espèce de de sacrifice de votre corps
dans un moment tournant spectaculaire
vous est grisé avec un moment de
croyance dans l'action mais en fait d'un
point de vue dynamique vous vous êtes
détruit comme sujet politique et je ne
crois pas qu'il soit très très
intéressant politiquement des points de
vue de l'efficacité pratique de se
livrer ainsi à l'appareil d'état ayant
fait d'accomplir ce qu'il veut c'est à
dire de pouvoir vous détruire donc moi
je suis favorable à des stratégies plus
subtile de conquête de l'appareil d'état
de transformation de l'appareil d'état
et je ne pense pas effectivement que la
violence soit sauf dans quelques cas
très particulier de légitime défense
note aux défenses d'urgence quoi comme
d'une terreur semée sur la question du
nucléaire par exemple que ce soit une
forme d'action particulièrement
puissante d'autant qu'elle renvoie alors
peut-être on n'en parle jamais au
fétichisme de la police moi je crois que
l'affrontement avec la police ou
l'action de la police occupe une place
beaucoup trop grande en fait dans le
mouvement social on a tous l'impression
qu'il se passe quelque chose dans les
manifestations quand on tape un policier
ou quand un policier nous tape que c'est
un peu la confrontation avec la police
qui qui est le moment où une
manifestation existe en vérité est que
s'il n'y a pas de fight avec la police
c'est comme si s'était rien passé et
cette espèce de fétichisme de la police
en fait à mon avis il est un piège dont
il faut se méfier parce que il fait que
petit à petit on
les objectifs de base ou les
revendications de base de la
manifestation sont oubliés et tout
devient du lance policière pratiques
policières août contre la police et la
police se substitue au sujet
substantielles qui petit à petit
disparaît c'est alors on perd
complètement les raisons pour lesquelles
heureusement oui vous dit très bien
qu'au fond au bout d'un moment et on l'a
très bien constaté egli gilet jaune
on finit par lutter contre la répression
contre la violence policière et on en
oublie
pourquoi ont lutté au départ et ça ne
devient plus que des manifestations des
slogans des revendications contre la
répression contre les violences
policières
c'est quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup
frappé moi je vends des jeunes pour moi
était un grand mouvement gâchée à cause
de ça mais pas seulement parce que les
gens ne seraient responsables et aussi
parce que c'est une stratégie de la
police en fait d'emmener les gens sur le
terrain de la police pour plus parler
des sujets de fond mais que dans lequel
on s'est un peu laissé enfermer j'ai été
très frappé par le fait qu'au début la
question des gilet jaune le sim de rufin
on avait parlé c'est la question de la
fin c'est la question de la sélection de
la santé cinq sens du déplacement c'est
la question de la misère vraiment la
misère misère et ça c'était quand même
langer d'une insurrection extrêmement
puissante et de ce point de vue
extrêmement à gauche qui s'était produit
dès novembre des descentes mais petit à
petit la question de la répression
policière qui a été réellement il ya eu
des mutilations il ya déjà arrachés ça a
été vraiment sanglant est extrêmement
grave a occupé une place démesurée enfin
tout à fait fondamental dans le
traitement d'un gilet jaune et à la fin
on avait l'impression de voir une
manifestation de gilet jaune le seul
sujet c'était que qui a été tabassé
comment on a été tabassé qu'est ce qui a
été produit comme forme de répression et
on a complètement oublié leurs
revendications substantielles qui est le
principe des gels et je ne leur donne
pas je le dis être tabassés pendant une
manifestation prend le risque d'être
mutilée prendre le risque d'avoir une
main arrachée c'est un pur scandale et
c'est une honte de la part de l'état et
de ce qui s'est passé sous le maquereau
nice mais il faut absolument de dénoncer
mais en même temps et une certaine
manière d'avoir transformé ce sujet
comme étant le sujet majeur en vérité
des choses que c'était un mouvement qui
était seulement confrontés à la question
de la police qui fait qu'on a oublié
totalement de paris les enjeux sociaux
politiques socio-économiques et son
fondement d'un tel mouvement et qui à
mon avis font partie d'une opération de
diversion dont le pouvoir est tout à
fait conscient en nous emmenant sur le
terrain de la prise pour plus que nous
parlons des systèmes et des questions
économiques ou sociaux social de base et
donc il faut se voilà typiquement un
cadre d'un puissant c'est à dire c'est
la manière dont croyant faire que
chose on est en train de s'autodétruire
hélas en croyant qu'on a fait monter
monter monter un sujet sur la violence
policière
est ce qu'on n'a pas en quelque sorte
perdu le contact avec la seule version
authentique que porter le gilet jaune je
dis ça sans du tout condamné la question
de la réflexion sur la police j'ai écrit
un livre à kassa traoré le combat damas
je pense qu'il ya des luttes dont la
question centrale est la question
policière notamment dans les quartiers
populaires et le traitement des jeunes
verts sont noirs et arabes où la
question carcérale mais en même temps
dans d'autres types de mouvements
quand la question policière devient plus
important que la question de fond alors
à mon avis une défaite du mouvement
ce que vous dites également dans ce
livre geoffroy de lagasnerie c'est qu'au
fond il faut bien reconnaître que la
tactique des adversaires de la gauche
était bien plus porteuses elle a bien
mieux réussi que les que la tactique que
le que les tactiques de gauche et que
donc la gauche devrait s'en inspirer
au fond il n'y a pas eu de manifestation
de patrons pour déréguler
les les services publics par exemple de
même il n'y a pas eu de pétition signée
par l'industrie pétrolière
et pourtant et pourtant on nous dit que
ce sont eux les maîtres du monde donc
mais comment s'inspirer justement de
tactique qu'on n'a pas vu en tout cas la
gauche ne les a pas vu venir
oui absolument mais moi je suis très
frappé par le fait que très souvent on
dépeint le paysage politique sous la
forme d'un affrontement entre les forces
de gauche et forces du progrès de la
critique sociale et on appelle de
l'autre côté l'ordre économique ou
l'ordre social et y aurait une ps2 ordre
qui auraient des défenseurs etc de
l'autre des gens qui voudraient défaire
l'ordre au se battre contre leur gré
donc on a l'impression comme ça d'une
inégalité des armes et à ce qu'on oublie
à mon avis totalement
c'est pourtant ce que très souvent la
droite n'allait pas du tout pour l'ordre
le totalement changé leurs valets
subversives d'ailleurs elle passe son
temps à vouloir faire des réformes à
vouloir attaquer l'état présent
l'extrême droite bien entendu mais la
droite aussi le néolibéralisme et et une
transformation majeure de la rationalité
politique au cours des trente dernières
années
donc ce n'est pas vrai que c'est l'ordre
contre le mouvement ces deux mouvements
vous avez un mouvement social
progressiste mouvement social le
conservateur aux réactionnaires qui
s'affrontent qui ont chacun leurs
techniques ayant chacun leur forme pour
apposer leur rationalité or force est de
constater que depuis trente ans les
techniques du mouvement social
conservateurs ont été plus puissante que
les techniques du mouvement social
progressiste
donc est-ce qu'on pourrait pas à ce
moment là des fétichisé nos méthodes
d'action et subvertir l'opposition entre
méthode subversive méthodes
traditionnelles pour essayer de
s'inspirer des méthodes traditionnelles
dans le champ de la gauche eva moi j'ai
beaucoup lu à ce moment là pour ce livre
les histoires du néolibéralisme de
l'infiltration des eaux libéral ou en
fait
yann texas et bo bo de leur intelligence
même si jamais ce sont des ennemis mais
de la iec par exemple aux historiens qui
ont dit nous on a laissé par exemple la
gauche faire des manifestations et
prendre les médias dans les années 50 et
60 ça ne va pas du tout intéressé et
dominés ils avaient tous les médias et
tous les campus étaient pour
il faisait des grandes manifestations
les années 60 la guerre du vietnam etc
donc on les a laissé faire mais nous ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a fondé des
écoles de l'élite les écoles de gens du
pouvoir on a fondé desserts comme la
société du mont pèlerin ou y avait 50
personnes on a formé des banques et
centre où il a formé des ministres on a
réformé les programmes d'économies des
grandes écoles de commerce et des
grandes écoles politique on a infiltré
les lieux de la gouvernance etc
et petit à petit en fait quand la gauche
croyez qu'elle dominait parce qu'elle
dominait et j'aime uniquement le paysage
cultural au public en quelque sorte
notre façon souterraine infiltrer les
institutions par un programme très long
de d'acclimatation à un nouveau
programme idéologique
un programme qu'il faut compenser comme
révolutionnaire parce que ça a
transformé logiciel de pensée de l'état
de la gestion de l'hôpital gestion
d'écoles la gestion de l'écologie donc
assez un programme révolutionnaire pas
du tout conservateur et qui en fait par
cette infiltration et bien comme ils
disent on a changé le monde
à 50 ans 30 ans et en 30 ans en ayant
infiltré les institutions de cette
manière là on était beaucoup plus
puissant que la gauche qui se croyait
puissance mais quand ils se croisent
puissante en fait elle était en train de
perdre le contact avec les dieux de la
transformation et de prendre une des
questions que je me pose c'est est-ce
que l'infiltration le consciente en
infiltration la long terme une
infiltration culturel les institutions
des écoles des dominants les cerveaux
des dominos serait pas une technique
extrêmement importante dans la gauche
devrait s'inspirer pour essayer de
gagner dès qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que là la prise du pouvoir
idéologique parler ce que l'on appelle
les néolibéraux c'est ce que vous
appelez n'est une insurrection réussi
telle qu'il faut bien comprendre que les
chats richard nixon ça n'a rien à voir
avec ronald reagan qui n'a rien à voir
avec avec donald trump c'est à dire que
c'est pas du tout les mêmes
il ya eu une véritable subversion qui
s'est effectué à l'époque et richard
nixon pour les néolibéraux c'était un
étatiste conservateur et un étatisme
avait absolument enchanté pour mieux
absorber les néo libéraux considèrent
toute façon qu'on vit encore dans des
formes très étatiste de gouvernements
des sociétés mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
et je pense pas qu'on vive dans une
société néolibérale janvier à la fin du
livre je pense que le duo libéralisme
est très largement un mot écran pour
comprendre la rationalité politique et
nos sociétés nous ne vivons pas dans de
souhaiter une libérale
le libéralisme est favorable très
majoritairement à la liberté de
circulation intégral on prépare les
politiques migratoires des états soient
très favorables à l'accueil des migrants
de libéralisme eux favorables à la
légalisation de toutes les drogues
on va dire que c'est ce qui se passe
nous libérer sa faveur de travail du
sexe le néolibéralisme est favorable à
le démantèlement des monopoles le
néolibéralisme est favorable je ne sais
plus j'ai un exemple qui m'échappent
mais en tout cas de l'avenue maurice mme
aubé y est favorable à l'abolition du
système carcéral quasiment donc en fait
si on va au bout du répéter nos libéral
on peut pas du tout dire aujourd'hui
qu'on est gouvernée généralement par une
racine et enoh l'hiver il ya des
endroits de rationalité qui sont
gouvernés néolibérale mans je pense à la
banque je pense à l'investissement
public à l'hôpital etc
mais globalement voilà c'est mieux comme
ça de penser des doctrines qui se sont
imposés dans certains espaces notamment
de la gestion des états et de l'économie
qui se sont mis en place le management
quoi et ça par contre ça a été une
subversion réussi et c'est une
subversion ça qu'il faut bien content ça
fait ça a été en guerre contre logiciel
d'état contre les hommes d'état contre
l'idée d'intérêt public contre les dieux
plan et c'est qu'elle est fondamental
que la formation des agents des années
50 ans des années 60 donc ça a été une
lutte à l'intérieur de l'état contre
l'état et qui a fonctionné ça c'est
important pour moi de le dire parce que
on a trop une vision unifiée de l'état
n'a trouvé une vision unifiée de les
élites ou des dominants comme s'il y
aurait une forme de deux programmes
uniques et en fait c'est pas du tout
vrai il ya eu des luttes à l'intérieur
du champ de l'état pour transformer les
perceptions et les cadres de perception
et le néolibéralisme était en guerre
contre les élites économiques
bureaucratique des années 60 et a gagné
sa guerre donc c'est pas parce qu'on n'a
filtré une institution qui ont échangé
par l on peut aussi la changer et le
très très très souvent là des arguments
contre l'infiltration si vous allez être
récupéré et donc vous allez rien pouvoir
changer si jamais vous devenez juge
devenait ministre sait jamais vous
devenez je sais pas moi industrielle
vous avez rien pouvoir changer moi je
crois que ce n'est pas du tout vrai et
de libéralisme est un très bon exemple
du fait que parfois on peut changer les
institutions et ce n'est pas elle qui
nous change
mais vous dites au fond à la fin de ce
livre les geoffroy de lagasnerie que la
gauche est bien s'attaquer à des grands
mouffe un peu vide de sens
le néolibéralisme en est un on y voit
une cohérence pour une venez de nous
expliquer qu'elles n'existent pas en
réalité
donc en fait on boxe l aveugle contre 1
contre un ennemi qu'on a beaucoup de mal
à définir de croire par exemple que la
france aujourd'hui est gouverné par les
néolibéraux et quelque chose d'absurde
à partir du moment où en france le
capitalisme est entièrement adossés à
des tapas complet donc on peut parler de
néolibéralisme
mais on continue quand on était de
gauche a invoqué le néolibéralisme comme
on va invoquer le patriarcat le
colonialisme
et avec ces grands mots contre
lesquelles on lutte au fond on perd
beaucoup de temps d'après vous c'est
vrai que je pense que l'un des bases que
doit accepter la gauche et que le monde
est chaotique le monde est hétérogène et
le monde est conçu de différents
systèmes de pouvoir qui sont
relativement indépendants les uns des
autres qui sont pas nécessairement relié
entre il faut toujours penser par
système on est de gauche vous avancez
individuellement il faut pas penser en
termes de bavures d'individus il faut
bien sûr penser des systèmes de pouvoir
dont il s'agit de transformer le
fonctionnement pour essayer de diminuer
les effets pouvoir qui fait peser sur
des individus mais en même temps le
risque de la pensée par système qui est
très puissante à gauche c'est d'essayer
de restituer une forme de cohérence et
de globalité du monde qui en fait
éloigne de la possibilité de toute
transformation et qui fait qu'il ya une
logique perverse du discours politique
où on croit qu'on est d'autant plus fort
commentant généralité or en fait tout le
monde en généralité moins on sait
pourquoi lutter non ces quads et faire
danser quoi faire et moi je pense que
vous pensez de gauche et puissante quand
elle peut identifier des mesures
concrètes à prendre et les mettre en
place pour transformer des systèmes de
pauvres et en voie très très bien aller
mouvement par exemple sur sur la police
ou sur la question des quartiers
populaires de moi me suis beaucoup
impliqué alors je suis maintenant
d'accord avec cette analyse en un sens
mais qui vont dire voilà ce n'est pas
seulement la question des quartiers
populaires c'est parce qu'en la police
élections du colonialisme c'est
l'impérialisme c'est le genre c'est le
racisme etc
c'est de l'état capitaliste l'état
impérialiste en fait vous dit comme ça
si vous voulez régler la problème de la
mise à mort des jeunes garçons des
quartiers populaires par la police vous
devez défaire l'impérialisme occidental
le racisme le colonialisme dont vous
avez de montée en généralité mais de
façon tellement abstraite qu'à la fin
vous pouvez plus rien faire parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si jamais
vous devez des plantes et de l'état
polonais litho l'état impérialiste pour
qu adama traoré ne meurt pas va vous le
ferez jamais et donc il va continuer à
mourir dans un fait c'est une manière de
montée en généralité qui fait croire
qu'on se donne du pouvoir alors avec ans
ed possède une capacité d'action
concrète sur les mesures ou des
techniques sont responsables de la mise
à mort d'un certain nombre de gens et
donc je crois qu'effectivement il faut
que la gauche trompe avec un certain
recours aux abstractions incantatoire
aux attractions vide aux abstractions
purement discursive en vérité qui permet
de se faire applaudir et d'apparaître
comme radicale pour être beaucoup plus
radicale parce que tu radical s'est
transformé les choses et ça n'est pas se
faire plaisir et se faire applaudir par
ceux qui vous aiment davance le pire
peut-être se seraient ceux qui invoquent
en permanence la convergence des luttes
parce qu'à partir du moment où on attend
la convergence des luttes
on risque d'attendre longtemps et on ne
lutte plus
du tout attendre la jonction entre les
ouvriers et les étudiants attendre la
jonction entre les étudiants et les
jeunes des quartiers populaires attendre
la jonction entre les cités de banlieue
et les gilet jaune c'est se paralyser
soi-même là encore c'est se condamner à
l'impuissance politique d'après vous oui
la gauche elle est impuissante tant
qu'elle n'aura pas rond auront pu avec
l'ère de la généralité et la cohérence
en vérité ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que les buts dans sociale et sont
spécifiques elles sont singulières elles
ont leur autonomie elles ont leur
système de pouvoirs spécifiques à
abattre et que paradoxalement les
mouvements sociaux tels qu'ils se
déploient pour ces mouvements sociaux
étudiants les groupes entre la migration
en évoluant sur la police sur l'écologie
sur le capitalisme ont toujours avoir
spontanément comme réflexe lorsqu'ils
vont émerger au lieu d'essayer de
désigner le système de pouvoirs
spécifiques ils ont en place de comment
est-ce qu'on peut essayer de le défaire
concrètement juridiquement
institutionnellement avoir une espèce de
fantasme comme ça de rejoindre
l'ensemble des autres luttent donc les
étudiants de rejoindre les migrants les
sans papiers
[Musique]
l'âne et écologistes de la lutte
féministe exeter et c est cette espèce
de course un peu à la généralité qui
prend la forme de l'injonction à la
convergence des luttes produit en fait
une espèce de nemours bizarre le
mouvement passe plus de temps restait de
rejoindre d'autres mouvements que de se
développer lui-même ce qui fait qu'à la
fin il se mutile lui-même dans le même
moule se développe parce que il perd
tout contact avec les effets pouvoirs
concrets qu'ils essayent de d'affronter
et surtout qui barrent d'une erreur
majeure intellectuelle c'est le fait
qu'il n'y a pas de centre du monde c'est
à dire qu'il n'y a pas de lieu de
pouvoir central qui concentre l'ensemble
des dimensions et ensemble d oppression
dans la réalité les oppressions elles
sont et spécifiques elles s'activent les
systèmes de pouvoirs particuliers et
donc si vous transformez pas rentrer la
question étudiante la question de la
police dans les quartiers populaires où
l'action de la prison il très basique
que vous ne faisait pas du tout la
question néolibérale où la question de
la démission masculine la question des
drogues c'est des cités de pouvoir très
très très différents et donc si jamais à
chaque fois vous cherchez un point
fictif mythologique au spectacle vous
deviez converger en fait l'essentiel de
vote lui tu vas concert c'était à aller
vers quelque chose qui n'existe pas et
donc en fait à vous autodétruire plutôt
que d'identifier ce qui existe
concrètement et ce sur quoi vous
pourriez véritablement agir si je vous
ai bien compris nuit debout par exemple
c'est ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire
de boer s'en souvient pendant des
semaines la place de la république peu
plus par des ateliers des gens qui
parlent de tout et tout non seulement on
doit se sentir concerné par tous mais
tout comme unique exactement
paradoxalement une nuit debout pour moi
d'une part c'est l'un des formes
politiques a été responsable de l'échec
de la mobilisation sur la loi travail
parce qu'elle a fait complètement cassé
les énergies d'une mobilisation
spécifique sur un problème spécifique à
une espèce d'incantation général seront
faits la constitution mais elle était si
l'un des lieux de la mythologie pure
vérité moi ce qui me fera beaucoup en
fait dans mon livre précédent la
conscience politique et dans celui à ce
petit manuel
je pense que la politique est souvent
présenté comme le lieu de la rationalité
de la délibération de la réflexion est
en fait peut-être un lieu plus
mythologique regarder dans les
catégories qu'on emploie dans nuit
debout la catégorie de constitution de
deux démocraties sont des fêtes des mots
cure m'envient des finances n'a aucun
sens d'un point de vue la réalité
politique ou mythologiques et
traditionnel dans ses formes qui sont le
rassemblement l'occupation a chanté les
chansons en faire des discours vont qui
peuvent être importants à certains
moments mais qui est très souvent sont
purement inefficace et rythme au début
c'était la concentration des voeux sur
des mythologies politique conceptuel et
des rituels
politique inefficace et la convergence
des deux à produire des moments les plus
faibles en vérité qui ait jamais existé
sur la terre de gauche et je pense que
c'est vraiment rompant avec cette image
là qu'on peut essayer de redevenir un
peu puissant politiquement
dernière question geoffroy de lagasnerie
ce livre est un et un manuel de lutte
on l'a dit c'est bien un livre de
stratégie de tactique il s'adresse à la
gauche parce que vous êtes de gauche
parce qu'elle est impuissante
politiquement mais au fond la droite et
l'extrême droite pourrait l'utiliser de
la même manière je me battrai contre et
si jamais le fond mais non non je ne
sais pas quand même mois la droite et la
gauche les français n'existent pas dans
ma tête je crois à l'autonomie de la
gauche je crois à l'autonomie de ces
problèmes le croit l'économiste c'est
chiant l'adresse je crois à l'autonomie
de ses pensées moi je ne lis jamais un
excellent de droite parce que le fait ça
n'existe pas ça ne m'intéresse pas je ne
vais jamais une télé de droite va venir
ça tout ça ne me concerne pas et donc je
ne suis jamais jamais posé la question
de mon rapport à la droite puisque je
n'ai aucun rapport avec la droite
en tout cas c'est peut-être ce que vous
croyez si beaucoup
geoffroy de lagasnerie sortir de notre
impuissance politique ça vient de
paraître chez fayard et ben merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
je